we're here in the dark outside the Royal  Society the UK Academy of Sciences and  we're here for a really special occasion  Neil Barnes is getting an inaugural  award the first award for technicians  that has been given by the Royal Society  Nails award is named after Isaac  Newton's assistant  hawkesby and before the ceremony  Rupert and Virginia from the archives  here at the Royal Society have taken  Neil down into the archives and shown  him all sorts of treasures many of them  I haven't seen connected with Hawke's  Bay and the role of technicians in  science  December the 26 1704 I think it didn't  even give him the day after Christmas  office  thank you  serious  [Music]  ly  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  foreign  [Music]  Francis hawkesby who designed this  particular instrument with its two  cylinders is active in the early years  of the 18th century mostly he knew Isaac  Newton and was his lab assistant if you  like